what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
spider-man no way home crushed it at the
box office and it continues to crush it
at the box office which is incredibly
good news for us because that means
they're going to make more spider-man
movies and not just with one spider-man
but now with multiple different
spider-man hopefully at this point in
time i assume most people have seen
spider-man no way home or at least have
seen pictures or leaks from it and they
know about spider-man knowing home but
here's your last spoiler warning
spider-man no way home had three
spider-men together in it andrew
garfield spider-man and toby maguire
spider-man joined tom holland and now
rumors are starting to go around that
the massive success of spider-man no way
home is going to start to produce more
spider-man films like an amazing
spider-man 3 for andrew garfield the
introduction of miles morales and a
spider-man movie that has the three
spider-man andrew toby and tom in it
from the very beginning of the film
which would be something that would just
be a massive and fantastic movie and
although these are just rumors for right
now a lot of these actually do make
sense coming from a studio standpoint a
fan base standpoint and simply a movie
standpoint so let's break down what we
could possibly get as far as spider-man
movies coming in the future and talk
about a new deal that tom holland might
be getting with sony and marvel right
now of course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu and spider-man news so
first off many of you might have heard a
rumor about tom holland possibly getting
the deal of a lifetime from sony and
marvel we don't know much about this
because it hasn't been confirmed in any
way but it simply makes sense and this
seems to happen after almost every big
actor in the marvel universe finishes a
film trilogy or a couple of films or a
big team up movie for example when the
mcu started robert downing jr got paid
500 000 for the very first iron man film
but by the end he got paid around 75
million for avengers end game so yeah
this happens quite frequently as actors
get bigger and more popular in their
characters in the marvel universe become
more prominent and important new
contracts happen now disclaimer this is
something that is good news this isn't a
new negotiation between sony and marvel
on whether or not to keep spider-man in
the mcu kevin feige and amy pascal of
sony have already come out and said they
are working on the next mcu spider-man
franchise with tom holland he's staying
in the mcu there's no new negotiations
on that front everything's fine so this
new deal seems to be simply about money
and how many films he's going to appear
in now i would assume he would get
another trilogy plus a couple of team-up
movies because i would actually guess
that he would go on to be a big part of
the new avengers team despite everybody
having forgot who peter parker was they
do still know who spider-man is and
let's be honest if doctor strange could
do a spell to make everybody forget he
could probably do a spell to make
certain people remember so i'm not
really too worried about that but the
rumor right now says deal of a lifetime
so i'm assuming that it's a lot of money
and that just makes perfect sense
because right now he is the most popular
superhero in the world spider-man no way
home is one of the biggest movies of all
time right now in the box office and
we're in a pandemic so that's pretty
powerful plus not to mention spider-man
alone just simply from the comics and
cartoons and rides and such is one of
the most popular superheroes in the
world already so i'm thinking tom is
walking out with a pretty good deal here
and like i said i'm thinking another
trilogy and a couple of team-up movies
now here's where things start to get
really really exciting now again only
rumblings of a rumor right now but it
seems like there could be a chance that
we could get a movie with the three
spider-man again but everybody is in the
film from start to finish so a whole
movie with tobey maguire andrew garfield
and tom holland and i'm assuming they
would call this movie spider-man and
this movie does have the potential if it
does get made to be bigger than no way
home essentially no way home would be
kind of like an infinity war and then
this spider-man movie would be the true
end game which hey i'm all here for i
love spider-man i think everybody loves
spider-man in some way shape or form and
it sounds like there is just a lot going
on right now not with just our
spider-man but with multiple spider-men
a lot of people by now have heard talks
that everybody really wants the amazing
spider-man 3 to happen andrew garfield
is even going on massive talk shows and
the hosts are asking him about what he
thinks about all of these fans wanting
the amazing spider-man 3 in which he
seemingly replied where the f for all
you people in 2014 now obviously he says
this in a joking matter but it's also in
a serious matter at the same time now
regardless of what happened in 2014
andrew garfield got redemption in
spider-man no way home and now there's a
lot of talk about the amazing spider-man
3 and with the way the post credit scene
for spider-man noah holmes set
everything up it does seem like there is
going to be a spider-man in the sony
verse where venom and morbius exists and
it doesn't seem like it's going to be
tom holland and like i've mentioned in
other videos tom hardy said that he
wants venom 3 to be a venom vs
spider-man film and if that happens it's
looking like andrew garfield's
spider-man is going to be the one we see
face off against tom hardy's venom
because tom holland is going to be
dealing with a completely different
venom symbiote in the mcu now andrew
garfield spider-man isn't the only one
that we could be seen pop up either in
the sony universe or the mcu in fact
this spider-man that i'm about to talk
about is most likely going to appear in
the mcu and that is miles morales i feel
like marvel and sony are slowly prepping
us to receive miles morales in the mcu i
think they started this with into the
spider-verse and now we are getting
across the spider-verse part one and
then part two not to mention we have
actually seen prowler the uncle of miles
morales in the mcu in spider-man
homecoming where he confirmed that he
does indeed have a nephew that exists in
the mcu who of course is miles and then
the big miles easter egg in spider-man
noway home where andrew garfield takes
off his mask and talks to elektro and
elektro tells him i thought you were
gonna be black andrew then apologizes
but then jamie foxx's elektra says
there's gotta be a black spider-man out
there somewhere which is obviously a
huge miles t since we are talking about
a movie that involves the multiverse
here and different spider-man variants
even though miles isn't a variant of
peter parker so it seems like the
groundwork is kind of being laid out
here and if they want tom holland's
peter parker to mentor miles morales and
then eventually miles take over the role
of spider-man in the mcu that could be
worked into the new deal that tom
holland could possibly be getting in his
next trilogy we could see him sort of
mentor miles morales through tom
holland's college years and miles's
younger years this could lead to miles
morales going on to join the young
avengers and this would also give us
somewhat of a tony stark and peter
parker relationship like we've had in
the past except this time peter parker
is kind of stepping into the role of
tony stark where he would mentor miles
morales and much like spider-man was
kind of a junior avenger at the time
until avengers infinity war miles
morales could actually go on to join the
young avengers team which is clearly
being set up in the mcu right now now
there's probably a little bit of time
until we get the actual young avengers
team which is good news because if
they're going to introduce miles in the
next spider-man film we probably have a
couple or a few years until we get that
film and i'd really love to see him as a
part of the young avengers and i'm
really looking forward to tom holland's
peter parker being on his own finally
taking care of himself and who knows
what his adventures are going to get
into but i cannot wait to see what
happens and i can't wait to see what
marvel and sony have in plan for us in
regards to a spider-man movie andrew
garfield's the amazing spider-man 3.
more tom holland movies and of course
the introduction of miles morales a lot
to look forward to hopefully some of
this if not all of this happens because
we will be very excited and happy fans
and let me know what you would be most
excited about in the comments down below
i think for me it would be the
spider-man movie just to see the three
spider-man back on screen together again
so be sure to let me know what yours
would be don't forget to like the video
and subscribe and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram or twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof